Trascrizione: Tamara Pession
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Esiste, secondo voi,
un elemento chiave, differenziante
che aiuta le persone
a raggiungere un obiettivo?
Probabilmente, ne esiste più di uno:
ma dalla mia esperienza,
ce n'è uno in particolare
che fa la totale differenza,
che è il saper guidare
il proprio elefante.
Ora, mi rendo conto
che vi lascio un po perplessi;
ma lasciatemi spiegare su quella
che è un po' la mia esperienza.
Sono un imprenditore.
E ho a che fare tutti i giorni
con imprenditori, professionisti,
sportivi, personaggi televisivi.
Che hanno un unico obiettivo,
che è quello di crescere.
Hanno un obiettivo molto, molto chiaro.
Ma al di là di quello che è
il piano di marketing,
il piano di business,
le attività che si devono fare con loro,
c'è un elemento che fa
la totale differenza,
che è il coraggio di cambiare.
Ora, sembra una banalità:
ma la verità dei fatti è che quando,
sia a livello professionale,
ma anche a livello personale,
siamo di fronte a un cambiamento,
tutti quanti abbiamo
una stretta allo stomaco,
se no sarebbe - se fosse così facile,
chiunque volesse intraprendere una dieta
magari la seguirebbe fino alla fine.
Magari ci iscriviamo in palestra
per fare qualche chilo,
ma non ci andiamo.
Gli imprenditori provano
a raggiungere risultati,
ma non li ottengono.
Quindi, cambiare è difficile.
E personalmente parlando,
il mio più grande cambiamento
fu quando diventai papà
per la prima volta.
Cambiamento numero uno:
diventavo genitore.
Non so voi, ma io le istruzioni
per diventare genitore non l'avevo.
E quindi -
Ma il secondo cambiamento,
ispirato, se vogliamo,
da quella che è un po'
la mia musa ispiratrice,
che è mia moglie,
era quello di diventare un imprenditore.
E quindi volevo regalare una libertà,
una tipologia di lavoro, di mestiere
che mi potesse permettere
di poter essere un po' più libero
rispetto, magari, a un lavoro che facevo,
a livello economico
ma soprattutto a livello temporale,
per poter decidere io i miei tempi
e poter stare con la mia famiglia.
E quindi cosa feci?
Definii un obiettivo:
e avevo un obiettivo chiaro.
E quando abbiamo un obiettivo,
cos'è che facciamo?
Ragioniamo, facciamo un progetto,
abbiamo magari obiettivi "smart",
ci mettiamo anche tanta determinazione:
ma il mio obiettivo
non riuscivo a conseguirlo.
Creavo business, e mi fallivano;
lanciavo e fallivo;
lanciavo e fallivo, lanciavo e fallivo.
Fino a che, un giorno, mia moglie,
la mia più grande fan, mi disse:
"Michele, sei sempre in start up.
Dai, forse non fa per te".
E quella, per me, fu una pugnalata.
Perché non so se vi è mai capitato,
ma quando la persona
di cui tu hai più fiducia
inizia a perdere fiducia
nei tuoi confronti,
inizi un po' a perdere
il terreno sotto i piedi.
Fui tanto vicino così dal mollare tutto,
e non inseguire il mio obiettivo.
Ma non lo feci.
Iniziai a studiare in modo diverso
per cercare di capire:
Cosa sto sbagliando?
Perché non raggiungo il mio obiettivo?
Eppure le cose le so, sono bravo.
E iniziai a studiare le cose
in modo completamente diverso,
a fare le cose in modo
completamente diverso.
E a distanza di tempo
sono diventato un imprenditore,
la famiglia si è allargata
e ho la fortuna di lavorare
con 40 persone che fanno parte
del mio team, del mio gruppo,
che lavorano con imprenditori,
quindi con persone,
e la aiutano tutti i giorni a crescere.
Quindi, voglio condividere
con voi due aspetti.
Il primo è: perché
è così difficile cambiare?
Il secondo è darvi cinque suggerimenti
che magari vi saranno di ispirazione oggi,
per poter migliorare il cambiamento
verso i vostri obiettivi.
Il cambiamento avviene
quando ci sono due elementi.
Uno dei libri che mi ha
più di tutti ispirato
è quello dello psicologo Jonathan Hain.,
nel suo libro: "Ipotesi: una felicità",
il quale diceva
che quando vogliamo cambiare,
il nostro lato razionale,
che è ciò che pensiamo
ci permetta di cambiare,
sia sufficiente.
Ma non è così:
serve un altro elemento da dover gestire,
che è il nostro elefante.
Il nostro elefante
è il nostro lato emotivo.
E dovete immaginare che,
quando vogliamo intraprendere
un cambiamento,
è come se dovessimo guidare un elefante.
Solo che, lato razionale,
la guida e il nostro elefante
hanno pregi e difetti.
La guida ha il pregio di essere analitico:
progetta, pianifica la visione.
Ma ha il difetto che è
un grande procrastinare, ha tanta paura.
Molto spesso è bloccato da essa.
Dall'altra parte, l'elefante
è la forza della natura,
è la vera energia che ci porta
verso quel cambiamento che vogliamo.
Ma dall'altra parte,
l'elefante è difficile da guidare
perché vuole una soddisfazione immediata,
si perde in tante cose;
e quindi, se riusciamo a combinare
la nostra guida e il nostro elefante,
allora arriviamo a quel
cambiamento che desideriamo.
Quali sono le cinque regole
che vi possono aiutare a cambiare?
Be', la prima è molto semplice:
di circondarsi di esperti,
di lasciarsi ispirare.
Oggi, se siete qua,
è perché volevate arricchire
la vostra esperienza,
e tornare con ispirazioni:
ma lo è un libro, lo è la formazione,
lo è una chiacchierata con amici,
lo è circondarsi di persone
che hanno già raggiunto
quel risultato che voi volete ottenere.
Nel 2002, a una cena con amici,
a Capodanno, abbiamo detto:
dai ragazzi, ma perché non facciamo
l'esperienza della maratona?
Ma sì, dai, da domani partiamo, va bene.
Partimmo in cinque;
il giorno dopo eravamo in tre;
dopo una settimana ero da solo.
Adesso mi sono iscritto
alla scuola agonistica
di Rimini, dove io vivo,
e iniziai a frequentare persone
che avevano già fatto la maratona.
E chiedevo loro: ma che scarpe usi?
Qual è l'abbigliamento?
Qual è il programma? L'alimentazione?
E questo fu molto utile,
perché aiutò la mia guida:
uno, a creare il progetto, la visione;
ma numero due, a farmi coraggio.
Perché se ce l'hanno fatta loro,
potevo farcela anch'io.
Il secondo suggerimento
è di creare un progetto,
ma anche una cultura.
Occorre un progetto chiaro.
Nel business, è palese che serve
un progetto ben definito:
ma lo serve anche se dovete
intraprendere un viaggio.
Ma non un viaggio,
una settimana organizzata:
un vostro viaggio, di quelli veri.
Occorre pianificarlo nei dettagli:
dovete tranquillizzarla, la vostra guida.
Ma dall'altra parte,
sappiate già che dovete mettere in conto
che ci deve essere, anche,
una cultura dello sbagliare.
E se volete inserire,
in questo vostro viaggio,
un vostro figlio, un marito,
un atteggiamento che magari
non riuscite a cambiarlo,
ma sta inseguendo
questa tipologia di progetto
che avete voi creato,
bene: sappiate che sbaglierà.
Non penalizzatelo.
Questo, per esempio, è il mio team
di marketing della mia società.
Come vedete, sembra una foto
in cui sembrano dodici matti.
La realtà dei fatti
è che tutti i giorni lavorano
con grande impegno su progetti.
Ma c'è anche una cultura del fallimento:
chi è che sbaglia? chi fa!
Pensate che Google permette
ai propri collaboratori
di fallire fino al 40%
dei propri obiettivi annuali,
perché se tutti dovessero
raggiungere il 100%
vorrebbe dire che non hanno tarato
gli obiettivi abbastanza in alto.
Terzo suggerimento:
mettete il pilota automatico.
Perché?
Ci sono centinaia di ricerche scientifiche
che testimoniano il fatto
che le nostre risorse mentali
non sono infinite.
Chi di noi, magari,
è più produttivo la mattina,
chi magari più produttivo la notte:
questo poco importa.
Ma sappiate che avete un tempo limitato.
Mettere un pilota automatico,
creando delle abitudini,
ci porterà a far sì
di andare nella direzione
quasi senza accorgercene.
Vi ricordate, le prime volte,
quando dovevate imparare a guidare?
La cintura, ok, la frizione,
lo specchietto - oddio, adesso parto.
Adesso salite in macchina e partite,
e andate in ufficio al lavoro
senza neanche più pensarci.
Quello è il pilota automatico.
E per farlo, occorre
saper gestire il tempo:
ma non, come pensano in tanti,
"devo gestire il tempo".
Il tempo è sempre quello per tutti:
dipende dall'azione che facciamo
per poter gestire al meglio
con delle "trazioni", ovvero abitudini
che ci portano in una gestione migliore,
al posto delle "dis-trazioni",
che sono attività - telefono,
social - che ci portano via tempo.
Quindi, focalizzatevi sulle trazioni
per creare delle abitudini
che vi portino a mettere
il pilota automatico.
Io le misi quando scrissi
il mio primo libro
in cui tutti i giorni, tutti i giorni,
il sabato, domenica compresa,
scrivevo due ore.
E l'ultima mezz'ora non facevo altro
che scrivere i punti
che dovevo scrivere il giorno dopo,
in modo tale che, quando tornavo,
non mi dovevo riscaldare,
pensare cosa devo scrivere,
o magari farmi distrarre
dai social, dal computer:
sapevo già cosa dovevo fare.
E scrissi un libro in 30 giorni.
E fino a qui, siamo stati sulla guida.
Ma è l'elefante, che fa la differenza.
Dovete cercare di capire qual è,
per voi o per le persone
che volete aiutare a cambiare.
E magari, vi ripeto,
può essere un figlio, un marito,
una moglie, un collaboratore.
Qual è la vera emozione trainante?
Qual è il vero perché?
Vi dicevo che io ho a che fare
tutti i giorni con gli imprenditori;
e gli imprenditori più virtuosi,
non solo quelli che vogliono crescere
perché semplicemente
vogliono aumentare il fatturato,
sono quelli che vogliono lasciare
un'impronta nel mondo:
creare un impatto sociale,
sostenibile, economico, più ampio.
Quello è il motivo vero.
Quando mi allenavo per la maratona,
tante volte mi chiedevano:
"Perché corri, Michele"?
E io dicevo: il motivo principale
fu che ai tempi mio padre
aveva un brutto male,
che poi se lo portò via.
E volevo allenarmi
per poter fare la maratona,
per poter dimostrare a lui
che avevo veramente imparato
la sua lezione,
che era quella di non mollare mai.
E la medaglia che presi,
quando poi feci le maratone,
la regalai a lui,
per dimostrargli quello che lui
mi aveva insegnato nella sua vita.
C'è sempre un'emozione che ci guida,
un'emozione trainante.
E l'ultimo suggerimento
è quello di premiare
l'elefante ad ogni passo.
Perché un grande cambiamento
è fatto da piccoli cambiamenti,
e ogni piccolo cambiamento va premiato.
Quindi, spezzettate ma premiate,
perché così il vostro elefante
sarà indirizzato
verso la direzione in cui vorrà.
Questo è il mio cane, si chiama Brio;
e quando insegnai a lui
a tornare chiamandolo per nome,
cosa facevo?
Gli dovevo dare un biscottino,
e poi premiarlo:
bravo, bravissimo!
E lui imparò che alla parola
"Brio" doveva tornare.
Bene, probabilmente lo facciamo -
per chi di voi ha un cane,
magari lo facciamo tanto con il cane,
ma magari poco con i nostri figli,
con i nostri collaboratori.
Dategli più "bravo":
alimentate il loro elefante.
Queste sono le cinque idee
che hanno aiutato me,
ma soprattutto che aiutano
le persone a poter cambiare -
non il lato business,
alla fine parliamo di persone.
Ma ci sono, ulteriormente, tre pensieri
che voglio condividere con voi.
Il primo è quello legato al -
l'avrete capito,
al saper gestire il cambiamento
considerando che dovete guidare
il vostro elefante.
Il secondo è legato al fatto
di avere più coraggio.
Recentemente, è uscita un'intervista
ad un'infermiera sull'HuffPost
che intervistava le persone
sul letto di morte:
"Le cinque ragioni sul letto di morte."
E al primo posto,
le persone hanno dichiarato:
"Non ho avuto abbastanza coraggio
di fare la vita che volevo".
Prendete più coraggio, osate di più:
cambiate lavoro, se non vi piace;
provate a inseguire il vostro sogno;
fate quella dichiarazione d'amore.
Ma inseguite i vostri sogni.
Ragionate, fate, con più coraggio.
E l'ultimo è la maratona.
Quella maratona l'ho fatta,
e addirittura ho fatto
la maratona di New York.
E tra le maratone di New York,
la cosa più bella
fu che il giorno prima
di intraprende la maratona
la ragazza che mi diede il pettorale
mi disse: "Enjoy Every Mile of Your Race",
che vuol dire: "Goditi
ogni singolo miglio della tua corsa".
Bene, lo feci davvero:
feci il mio peggior tempo
tra le maratone che ho fatto,
ma è la maratona in cui mi sono
divertito di più, come esperienza:
battevo il cinque alle persone,
chiamavo: "Come on New York! Yeah".
È stato bellissimo,
un'esperienza che porterò nel cuore
come esperienza di vita, non come corsa.
E questo lo voglio dire alle persone
che magari sono estremamente
focalizzate sull'obiettivo.
Ok, va bene;
ma sappiate che nel percorso
succedono delle cose
che, alle volte, sono ancora più belle
di quello che è l'obiettivo
che avevamo in mente.
Quindi, gestite la vostra guida,
non fatevi fregare da essa.
Gestite il vostro elefante,
abbiate coraggio.
Perché alla fine, i soldi vanno e vengono;
ma il tempo, no.
E per ultimo, godetevi ogni singolo passo
del vostro cambiamento.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)